australia is set to evacuate thousands
more people from sydney suburbs as the
region grapples with its worst flooding
in decades
heavy rains have swelled rivers across
new south wales state causing widespread
damage
emergency services feared that more than
50 000 people could be displaced as
forecasts show more rain
is on the way
a desperate attempt to save a stranded
horse
torrential rain and flush floods in
australia's state of new south wales
have cut
owners off from their animals for many
creatures
help has come too late
at least 18 000 people have been
evacuated from their homes as rivers and
dams overflow
some are trying to shore up their houses
as best they can
ahead of the looming waters
others have already seen their homes
ravaged by the flooding
oh everything downstairs carpets
cupboards everything's
gone but
labour was worse off than i am so you've
got to be thankful for small mercies
but residents have been warned that the
worst may still be to come
and told to brace for a difficult week
ahead
australia is being tested once again
the east coast of australia
predominantly new south wales but i
stressed also in south east queensland
has faced an extraordinary deluge over
recent days
in many places rains are expected for at
least the next 24
to 48 hours but i fear worse
the extreme downpours battering
australia's east have caused the worst
flooding in half a century
having already battled drought bushfires
and the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
over the past year
communities are feeling pushed to
breaking point
and we can speak now to poppy brown
she's the director of the australian red
cross for new south wales and the
australian capital territory
poppy thank you for joining us as we
heard dozens of communities have been
isolated
38 areas have now been declared disaster
zones
put this into context for us how dire is
the situation right now
well yes it has been a very difficult
few days here and
um as your montage said we have had 18
000 people evacuated
um we've supported over a thousand
people in evacuation centers those are
people who had nowhere else to go
um in some areas it's a once in a
century flood event
and a lot of these areas um suffered in
the bushfires about a year or so ago and
drought as well so
particularly it's been a particularly
hard couple of years for those
communities
and um this is just yet one more uh
setback for them so um we're trying to
do all our
all we can to support them in this
situation but it is a very difficult
time at the moment yeah what are the
biggest challenges you're facing right
now
so one of the things we're facing is the
fact that um
the waters have risen so quickly so in
some areas people have
had to be working in the middle of the
night they've had to evacuate
in just the clothes that they're wearing
so we've had people come to evacuation
centers
you know just in wet clothes with their
children with their animals
and they're in shock they've been
traumatized
you know all their possessions are in
their homes so
it's been very very difficult for those
people and also
a lot of concerns about you know the
livestock in the farms
and things like that so yeah it's it is
a very difficult time but our
communities are very strong and
resilient so
we will bounce back but um all the
agencies and the government is trying
the best that we can to uh to help our
communities at the moment
with tens of thousands of people already
displaced and more
rain forecast i mean what are you
telling people on how they can protect
themselves
yeah so what we're doing is we're very
much ensuring that everybody has an
emergency plan and if people are in
those areas that
look like they're in danger that um what
they should do is they should
uh go and stay with friends and family
should pack up their homes
if they need to move to higher ground
and make sure they follow all of the uh
instructions of the emergency services
and then that they will be safe what we
don't want to have is people
um you know needing to be rescued in the
flood um
because so far we have had no loss of
life so we want to make sure that it
stays
that way if more rain does come are you
worried that the situation could get
worse
oh absolutely so um it's a very volatile
situation at the moment
i know that in the sydney area
the big dam that the big water dam that
supports the sydney area
it's currently spilling over every
single day
enough water to fill sydney harbour so
that's the amount of water that's going
into the rivers
in that area and then they come
downstream and there's a risk of
flooding so
we're not over the worst yet um but we
certainly have our fingers crossed that
the rain eases and the flood situation
eases because
a lot of people are likely to be
impacted
poppy brown director of the australian
red cross for new south wales
and the australian capital territory
thank you very much
thank you
you